Hi guys, I am Arun Pradeep from CSE department and
I am going to talk about the challenge that I faced the first.
Okay, not going to talk about the first challenge. The recent challenge that
I faced is working on a project to which is a
interview practice. I took on the
timer for two minutes and I can't stop the timer. I need to speak continuously
for those two minutes, you may ask. So it's not a any big,
big issue. But the issue is the API key is not working properly.
So every time just talking two, two time, two minutes
continuously. And at the end it the message,
the content that I told are recorded for two minutes is there,
but it's not actually fetched by the API. So this
is the problem I am I actually faced. And that's
what I'm that's what the problem that is faced in recent times.